médiéval que moyen-âgeux notre dame d'oé
près de tours est surtout connu pour
être le seul hameau du val de loire où
jeanne d'arc ne s'est pas arrêté cet
oubli de la bergère lorraine irrite
piemme qui fait très fort fois avec sa
femme et ses enfants pourris compter ses
moutons et pour y refaire l'histoire de
france et de jeanne avec la complicité
des habitants
dans quelques instants vous retrouverai
piemme sur fr3 lors de notre magazine
historique de ce guide
[Musique]
pm l'humoriste distinguer sans origine
précise est née entre deux guerres comme
beaucoup d'entre vous mais cela l'a
vivement impressionné et tout comme la
bergère lorraine
il entend des voix heureusement pour
nous il est devenu un sujet régional en
épousant elisabeth une tourangelle de
notre dame d'oé et c'est dans ce bourg
non loin de tours qu'il vient entre deux
dessins se refaire une bonne mine de
crayon bien sûr tourangeau passe affamés
meurtris par l'histoire de france il est
né entre deux guerres faut-il encore le
rappeler piemme enragent car j'en da
lors de sa chevauchée épique y as un
siècle et demi est passé par tous les
hameaux du val de loire
sauf par notre dame d'oé et cet oubli il
ne peut l'oublier
neil lui pardonne grâce à la complicité
d aurélien c'est ainsi qu'on appelle les
indigènes de notre dame d'oé il va faire
comme dumas père un enfant à l'histoire
et à la pucelle d'orléans
nous vous invitons donc à le suivre dans
les rues de notre dame d'oé et à travers
le dédale du délire historique au
bucolique qui lui est propre
notre dame d'oé effleure la zone
industrielle de tours-nord peu à peu en
lacets par les tentacules des
constructions en dépit de tout et de
tours notre dame d'oé a su se protéger
du cancer urbain le village a gardé en
souvenir de jeanne sa pimpante fraîcheur
médiévale c'est un miracle et la bonne
lorraine n'y est sans doute pas des
congères
les nouvelles maisons sont de véritables
bijoux des chaumières d'art dont les
bâtisseurs descendante en droite ligne
des compagnons des cathédrales
écarquillés vaut qu'un quai au long de
ses ruelles tortueuses joliment temps
pas fait la rue du chapelet et sa maison
du tanneur échoppes du tisserand pas une
fausse note
rien n'est altéré c'est aussi beau que
les enluminures des très riches heures
du duc de berry
pourquoi diable piemme à notre dame d'oé
notre andrés et en touraine la touraine
où le voyait ses jardins la france c'est
entre orléans chinon c'est un lieu qui
est pétri d'histoire tous les villages
dans l'eure-et-loir ont vu passer jeanne
d'arc le cheval de jeanne d'arc à but
partout jeanne d'arc à coucher partout
contrairement à la légende et bien à
notre dame de et tout particulièrement
qui n'a pas véritablement son histoire
il ya un amour une adoration pour jeanne
d'arc et c'est ce lieu pétri d'histoire
qui nous intéressait c'est pour ça que
nous y tenons beaucoup
prenons l'exemple de cette plaque est
bien les habitants de votre ado les ont
donné le nom de la place principale de
leur village
le 11 novembre 1918 qui correspond
exactement à un demi siècle et deux
jours après la naissance de jeanne d'arc
gt est un pays qui a l'amour
je t'ai roi
[Musique]
ici il ya ces choses fabuleuses déjà
placé pour qui ça monsieur ribas et pour
cheval que jeanne d'arc jeanne d'arc
continue à être présente dans la mémoire
d'un coup d'état
de trouver la cbl ah bonjour au niveau
va bien des batailles apprend pour vous
connaissez jeanne d'arc aux jeunes a
connu plus venez souvent ici nous voir
personne très simple elle buvait de
l'eau et ça faut le dire a vraiment
maintenant et en tant que nous ne
l'avons pas vue bah oui le temps passe
voilà ma famille en fait je ne savais
pas ce qu'elle est devenue
ah non je ne sais pas non non je ne sais
pas si comme garçon ce que je préfère ne
pas lui dire la vérité
jaloux pas plus sages de plus elle se
voit la pucelle
c'est avec filtre car voyez vous ils
sont imprégnés par ces grandes pages de
l'histoire de france ceux qui veulent ça
traverse une crise économique certaines
mais les risques de son passé tout de
même la raison justement c'est que cette
richesse je trouve particulièrement dans
ce territoire de notre dame de m la
infiniment cannes
[Musique]
camille brisset taulier et camille
vous avez une histoire avec jeanne d'arc
ah oui en effet je travaillais pour elle
de même une facture impayée
[Musique]
bravo aux deux équipes et sera relié
organisa du matricule et adoré me mis
150 km au compteur à les sorties 1420
tôlerie remplacement déplaceront à la
dépose et repose remise en état des
glissières plus ponçage réglages la cote
de maille vide engrais âgées genouillère
total 240 et q5 sol plus élevée et je
n'ai jamais été payé témoin de plus
là
[Musique]
c'est pour le sacre et bien alors c'est
la première à gauche après l'église tout
droit pouvez pas vous tromper
[Musique]
c'est ici dans cette église que n est
guère à a créé le très bel oratorio de
paul claudel jeanne au bûcher et tous
les dimanches d'ailleurs le peuple sain
se précipitent pour entendre ce très bel
oratorio tous les matins également à
cette heure là jeanne chars
qui m'appellent
qui est-ce qui m'appelle dans emi cabine
contrairement à la légende ce n'est pas
à montoir que le général de gaulle a
rencontré jeanne d'arc c'est ici sur le
quai de la gare de notre dame deuil
il ya un certain temps et d'ailleurs on
a gardé en souvenir de cette rencontre
les fameuses voix de jeanne d'arc il ya
plusieurs voies qui font parie chinon
tour de la voie la plus importante
il ya même un certain endroit une voie
de garage qui a été gardé au cas où la
france aura encore besoin d'un appel
historique
en fait vous parlez de jeanne la pucelle
moi quand j'étais petit je sais pas du
tout ce que ça voulait dire jeanne
jeanne la pucelle
d'ailleurs c'est pas compliqué je
voudrais qu'on me disait jeanne la
ficelle bon et puis alors on va
expliquer c'est pas la ficelle on m'a
dit c'est la pucelle
alors je dis c'est quoi une pucelle vous
savez comment ça se passait de mon temps
on expliquait pas les choses comme on
m'expliquer les choses avec des images
n'est pas pas quand ça se fait un enfant
c'est très simple les garçons et les
filles c'est pas pareil
un garçon à 1 1
un garçon a un petit oiseau voilà et le
petit oiseau
ça s'appelle
ça s'appelle un ça s'appelle un robinet
et les filles n'ont pas de robinet et
non pas de petit oiseau alors un beau
jour de printemps le petit oiseau vient
tendrement poser son petit robinet sur
le bord de la coupe largement ouverte à
sa tendresse et il en tombe
mon petit enfant il en tombe quelques
petites graines
mais il ne faut pas que le petit oiseau
viennent manger les graines
parce que la cigogne va à son tour
déposé la rose dans le coeur du sou et
cela va donner à nouveau un petit
robinet qui donnera aussi un petit
oiseau et le petit oiseau fera tomber
des grêles dans la coupe est pas qui tu
assures - la grèce mais non le petit roi
tu ne mangeras les graines puisque c'est
le petit robinet qui met les graines
dans la coupe et le petit poisson lui va
se poser sur le coeur du ou oui mais
seulement voilà il faut y mettre de la
flamme
c'est et hier à la chandelle aujourd'hui
piemme est au courant au courant
électrique
bien sûr ceci est masculin féminin est
bien entendu un jour le masculin
rencontre le féminin voilà une légende
très ancienne prétend que les prises de
couleurs sont plus fortes que les prises
blanche
erreur d'après le rapport sur la
sexualité des français 39% des hommes et
45 % des femmes préfèrent avoir les
contacts dans l'obscurité totale
il faut constater qu'une trop grande
tension sur un réseau fatigué fait
parfois péter les fusibles aussi pour se
protéger contre ce péril la société
pratiques tels la répression sociale
certaine prise mâle sont également
femelles ce qui leur permet de recevoir
d'autres prise mâle qui sont également
femelle qui reçoit à leur tour n'est
prise mâle femelle même certaine prise
mâle qui sont triplement femelle qui
reçoivent encore à leur tour d'autres
prise mâle qui sont également des
femelles qui reçoivent encore des prises
mal qui sont également femelle qui
reçoivent encore d'autres prise mâle qui
ressemble quand d'autres suprises
femelle qui reçoivent records d'autres
prise mâle qui reçoivent encore d'autres
prises aux femelles
enfin ceci s'appelle de toute façon la
sexualité de groupe ou un groupe
d'animation avec rupture mais plus fort
que l'amour il y a l'amour bucolique
c'est pourquoi loin des soucis de la
ville des jours tranquilles pendant
qu'est ce que qu'est ce que vous dites
vouloir
[Musique]